what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic Wonder today is the day it
has officially happened James Gunn has
revealed the first chapter of the new DC
slate and let's not waste any time at
all let's dive into the video and talk
about what James Gunna said what he has
released and break it all down hey
everybody I'm James Gunn I'm the co-ceo
of DC Studios so as many of you know DC
has been disconnected in film and
television for a long time and it's one
of you know our jobs mine and Peters is
to come in and make sure the DCU is
connected in film television gaming and
animation that the characters are
consistent played by the same actors and
it works within one story okay so this
first part James Gunn basically
addresses the problem with the old DC EU
there wasn't really much continuity it
wasn't really connected they need to
have the same actors playing the same
roles whether that be in movies
television an animated series and also
as he mentioned gaming which is really
really cool so James Gunn and Peter
saffron are coming into DC and they're
making sure that everything connects but
for those wondering about say the Batman
or the Joker this is what he had to say
about these projects and if something is
outside of that like Matt Reeves Batman
or Todd Phillips Joker or Teen Titans Go
that it is clearly labeled as DC else
worlds outside of the mainstream DCU
continuity so if it is outside of the DC
Universe continuity it will be labeled
DC elseworld so that is very clear that
makes it to where there's really not any
confusion if it is not labeled DC else
worlds it is not a part of the DC
connected Universe now in the next part
he talks about four different projects
that are coming before his new DC slate
begins and also explains how the
universe is going to be reset now Peter
and I have gotten pretty lucky in terms
of the four projects that are coming out
over the next year first we have Shazam
Fury of the Gods Shazam has always been
off kind of in his own part of the DCU
so he connects very well that moves
directly into the flash a fantastic
movie that I really love that resets the
entire DC Universe then to move into
Blue Beetle a fantastic film about a kid
who's a marvelous part of the DCU and
then into Aquaman 2 which leads directly
into our next few projects which I'm
going to tell you about now so this was
what a lot of us actually expected The
Flash movie is going to reset the entire
DC Universe which honestly is just a
really smart way to do everything and
from there we're going to get Blue
Beetle Aquaman 2 and then we're going to
dive into his new DC slate which he is
titled chapter 1 Gods and Monsters now
James Gunn States in this video which he
has already stated in a tweet that him
and Peter have mapped out eight to ten
years of the DC Universe and much like
Marvel has their phases DC is now going
to have what James Gunn calls chapters
and it is also important to note that he
does say that this is only part of
chapter one not all of it now the first
project that he announced is a project
called Creature Commandos which is going
to be a TV animated show now here's
something that is extremely cool that
James Gunn has said not only about this
project but animated shows and live
action shows in general for the new DCU
he says that characters are going to go
into live action and over into animated
series and keep the same actor who
voices them and plays them and this is
amazing this is an incredible way to
keep the continuity and connectivity of
the DCU and not have confusion so he's
keeping everything connected very very
tightly so I'm absolutely loving this
idea now Creature Commandos is a very
James Gunn project the team was formed
for the second world war they were
formed by America to fight against the
Nazis they establish is something called
Project M where a scientist realized
that the enemies or people in general
were terrified of essentially monsters
so what did they do they conducted
experiments on soldiers turning them
into monster-like beings like werewolves
and they basically used them as a team
to do special missions so that's what
happens in the comics who knows what
they're going to do for the Animated
Series but I know James Gunn is a true
comic fan so I would expect something
pretty similar to this now the next one
he announced is a live action TV show
called Waller now most people know
Amanda Waller especially if you've seen
the most recent DC projects the latest
one being Black Adam and although the
universe is about to reset they are
continuing with Kind Of The Peacemaker
storyline and Amanda Waller's
involvement there because he clarifies
in this that Amanda Waller will be using
The Peacemaker team so I'm assuming that
this is going to tie into Peacemaker
season 2. and James Gunn seems to think
that this show is absolutely amazing and
it hasn't even filmed yet but here is
where things get really interesting and
James Gunn's announcement he says next
one is the big one the true beginning of
the DCU now this is where essentially
his live action Justice League DC
Universe begins new Superman new Wonder
Woman new Justice League in general
which leads us to believe since he says
this is the true beginning that Aquaman
Shazam the movies that he previously
listed in this announcement will not be
a part of this new universe moving
forward he was a little vague about
those other projects but since he says
that this is the true beginning of the
DCU we could probably assume that those
previously mentioned projects are not
connected to the new universe and it
starts off with Superman and what a
great way to start it off and we don't
know much about what it's going to be
about we just know it's going to be
called Superman Legacy and it has a
release date it'll release in theaters
July 11th of 2025 and James Gunn is
writing it himself we then move into
something that I am personally very very
very excited about and that is a show
called lanterns and James Gunn says it's
going to be a big Premier HBO series and
the cool part about this is is a lot of
people were talking about before which
Green Lantern they were going to bring
in is it going to be how Jordan is it
going to be Jon Stewart could it be Guy
Gardner but James Gunn announced amazing
news that it's actually going to be the
story of two Green Lanterns Hal Jordan
and Jon Stewart and he also said the
other ones were going to be thrown in
the mix there as well which is fantastic
but the story for this show sounds quite
amazing and what's even more exciting is
James Gunn says that they discover
something that links to the bigger
picture of the DC Universe now he states
that it is a terrestrial show which
means it is taking place on Earth or
directly related to Earth and he says
that it's kind of like a True Detective
show with the Green Lanterns being
essentially space cops with our two
Green Lanterns watching over Earth so
right away that sounds incredibly
exciting I think we can expect them to
deal with Earthly problems but also
space problems as well threats coming to
Earth and James Gunn even says they
discover a terrifying mystery that ties
into the larger story of the DC Universe
now I'm assuming that this is going to
be directly related to the big bad of
the new DCU and this is a new universe
the big bad could be anybody so if you
have thoughts on who you'd like to be
the first big bad of the new DCU please
be sure to leave those thoughts in the
comments down below now the next
announcement is what James Gunn calls
his passion project so you know it's
going to be good and that is the
authority which is going to be a movie
and here's what James Gunn has to say
about them next is a big movie called
The Authority The Authority is a passion
project of mine it's based on The
Marvelous wildstorm characters we are
now bringing into the DCU and will
interact with all of our primary DCU
characters The Authority are a group of
superheroes who think the world is
broken and they want to fix it by any
means necessary I think it's a very
different look at superheroes now the
authority is really cool because they
are heroes but at the same time the
world sometimes tries to go against them
and take them down because they do
interfere with worldly events and
governments however they do also protect
the Earth but like James Gunn said they
kind of do it in their own way and based
off of the pictures that James gonna
showed us we can expect to see
characters like Jenny Sparks the doctor
death blow Apollo Swift Jax hoxmore and
engineer then he announced a TV show
about the mascara where Wonder Woman is
from Called Paradise Lost and he
describes it as kind of almost like Game
of Thrones which is crazy interesting
and this is most likely going to give us
the origin of Wonder Woman in this show
now the next one is something I'm so
excited about and that is Batman a movie
titled the Brave and the Bold our
introduction to our new Batman and James
Gunn pretty much tells us everything
that we need to know about this project
the introduction of the dcu's Batman is
the Brave and the Bold the Brave and the
Bold is the story of Batman and his
actual son Damien Wayne this is based on
Grant Morrison's great comic book run
Damien Wayne is my favorite Robin he's a
little assassin who Batman tries to get
in line and so this is the story of the
two of them and the beginning of sort of
the bat family in the DCU so it's going
to be based off of the grant Morrison
run which includes things like the black
case book Batman and Sun the black glove
Batman and Robin Batman rip and many
other really really great ones now in
the comics Damian Wayne is the son of
Bruce Wayne and Talia al Ghul and I must
say this is quite interesting because it
seems like James Gunn is introducing
these new characters as younger
characters however during the grant
Morrison Batman and Son story Batman is
pretty much at the end of his career so
I'm curious to see how this will be
incorporated into the new DCU but I am
extremely excited about this then we get
a TV series about Booster Gold and it's
awesome the way James Gunn talks about
Booster Gold next up is a TV series
called Booster Gold Booster Gold is one
of comic's really popular cult Heroes he
is a fascinating guy he's a loser from
the future who uses future technology to
come back to present day and become a
superhero so that people will love him
it is basically the superhero story of
imposter syndrome on an HBO Max Series
so like you said Booster Gold is from
the future he's from the 25th Century
and he was a star he was a star football
player he earned his name booster but he
got a little greedy and he gambled on
his own games which ruined his future
essentially he became a security guard
at a museum the Metropolis Space Museum
and then he stole time travel technology
it went back into the past because he
thought he could use his future
information to make some money and also
be a superhero and ultimately he does he
does brag a lot he does take a lot of
credit usually for saving people but
he's a good guy and I'm assuming this is
going to be a very funny TV show then he
announced that we are going going to get
a huge film that is going to be about
Supergirl and it's going to be Supergirl
woman of Tomorrow we don't get a man of
tomorrow but we are getting a woman of
tomorrow so I am really excited about
this project because Supergirl is going
to be very different than Superman
because like James Gunn says Superman
was sent to Earth by his real parents
and then he was raised by loving parents
on Earth the Kents however Supergirl was
raised on a chunk of Krypton and like
James Gunn says she watched everybody
around her parents family friends
everything perish in a really bad way so
she is very different from Superman
she's very bitter and she's jaded as
James Gunn says and I think this is
going to be a really great film and it
sounds like James Gunn is going all out
for it and last but not least Swamp
Thing which is apparently going to be
some type of a horror film and James
Gunn states that it's going to be
tonally outside of the DCU so the tone
is going to be very different than all
of the other projects in the DCU however
it will still feed into the overall
story of the DCU so here we will get the
origin of Swamp Thing and Alec Holland
and there you have it part of chapter
one of our new DC Universe let us know
what you think about this in the
comments down below are you excited are
you happy are you disappointed let us
know all of your thoughts and please
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on the
latest DC news you can always follow us
on Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
me